reject your anus Embrace kyus Michael I
fundamentally agree it perhaps should be
called kalus but I have other issues
here you were commenting on how Uranus
sounds like if you want to go there I
will have you know that Uranus as a
planet is actually tipped on its axis
more than
90° which would mean its face is in its
own
butthole now we are lucky to have the
thing named Uranus to begin with William
hersel a Brit in the late
1700s he discovered Uranus a little bit
by accident but he discovered it and he
decided to name it after his benefactor
Good Old King George so for several
decades there was Mercury Venus Earth
Mars Jupiter Saturn and George